president zielinski wants fighter jets
what's a realistic proposition from the
UK the UK is not really in a position to
give any fighter jets because we don't
have enough to do what we need to do
however and what we can do and what
Rishi sunaka said is is offered training
and therefore starting to train
Ukrainian pilots and I understand
they're being trained on the Euro
Fighter jets
and then we can offer support and
impetus into the wider International
Community for jets to be provided there
are a number of different options yeah
this talk about the UK of course
training at Ukrainian Pilots but you
know it is the planes that zielinski is
calling for he's talking about you know
Ukrainian Pilots as being Kings
themselves they know how to fly planes
they just need the equipment where is
that going to come from what jets are
they likely to get from not just say the
UK and the United States but from around
the European block well look at the
different options that are out there you
know the UK the two jets that are being
flown at the front line at the moment
are the f-35b which is just coming into
service at top here that's the top bit
of tech we've only got 30 of them
they're they're fifth generation they're
very complex they're very secret they're
never going to go in we've got another
seven coming this year another 11 coming
um in a couple of years time the the
Mainstay of the British fighter jets or
the um the Euro Fighters we can see
there and actually they're in a number
of different other European countries
and in the Middle East there's over 570
of them around so there's a there's a
bigger pool of them some of them are
older ones I'm going out of service and
they're working through there other
options that have been discussed we've
got the F-16 and we heard a lot of talk
about that President Biden said the
Americans were not going to contribute
F-16 but the Dutch have said that they
might do there's over 4 000 of them
around the world so on share numbers
terms that could be the jet but it might
be too too complex for for the
ukrainians you're single-seater that's
more complex to operate to learn how to
fight it's not just learn how to fly but
to learn how to fight it moving on from
that the best option I think at the
moment is still the MiG-29 now there are
NATO countries that have got mig-29s
that were are brought into you and
brought up to Nato standards after they
came across from being former Soviet
Bloc countries and some of those are
being replaced by those countries they
could easily be passed the ukrainians
the ukrainians are flying those today
and they could get into that and work it
very quickly indeed and the UK could buy
some of them and guarantee support out
to countries that are donating those to
protect them and that would be a quick
way of getting things in and of course
we've got the the tornado and that's
been mentioned in in particular UK
tornadoes this is a British tornado
retired a couple of years ago but the
Germans are still flying them and a lot
of the UK spare parts went off to
Germany the Germany the Germans are
starting to retire them from next year
they could retire them earlier and
potentially donate some of those across
but again it's learning not just
learning how to fly is learning how to
fight it and to fight it with the
different weapon systems that are on
board that's where the complexity comes
in it seems inevitable that Ukraine will
get fighter jets from a number of
countries it's just the practicalities
that are being sorted out at the moment
what kind of numbers do they need to
make an impact in the war and how will
Jets feed into what's already been given
to them by Western countries number
numbers are very difficult line to go
down um because it's all about the
effect
um you know one type of you can have a
smaller number one type of jets um that
will beat a very large number of a
different type of jet so it's all the
effect that the ukrainians need and the
effect that ukrainians need is to be
able to put a protective bubble over all
of this complex high-end armor that
we're not giving them and that
protective bubble is is called creating
local Air superiority so to stop the
Russians from and been able to attack
the ground forces from the air
um and to do that they need to stop
Russian aircraft coming in it will shoot
down Russian missiles that are there and
they need to be able to attack Russian
Ground Forces further out to support
um the armor that's coming in because
the armor that's on the ground can
protect itself from ground threats it
can't protect itself from Air threats so
you need that air Superior RCP that's in
there and that's why the ukrainians need
jets are they going to be there in time
for a spring offensive no